first I didn't want to hear now just
like that there's lemon collected in the
locker room I was like we still have
some more games to play once two weeks
is here but you never know so I was just
like hey whatever coach is like he gave
me that look and I was like you know
what what the heck let's go do it so I'm
glad I did is this fun his like say if
it has if it ended today you know and
you know this day this this into the
season his last 16 games will we talked
about for a very long time and that's
something I'll always remember you know
at least I scored my last basket and
there'd be a a weird but cool memory
yeah it is it's just so it's a weird way
to say I'm calling the courier it really
is I mean you used to you know you
haven't you don't have any more games
left instead i tec technically have what
i will consider eligibility I have 15
games left technically but if not I'm
one with it and it's just that I said
it's just weird
you know as you know we were kind of
getting being briefed on everything
what's going on what you guys been
seeing all the second half you know I'll
just sit there like all right this is it
like that it ended like that you know so
probably tonight how it reflecting like
golly
it's just weird now I didn't foresee you
know I went from the hesitation of
starting the season and going through
the season to not really saying the word
retirement to you know having a
conversation with Colby was give gave me
that the confidence and comfort to talk
about retirement to this point where the
season's over when in my mind I know
there's 15 games left but we're not sure
yet so it's cool though
you know it's basketball has been good
to me I you know I've enjoyed each and
every moment of it good and bad so if
this is it it's all good I least I made
my last basket
yeah it's just like I said it's just
it's like it literally just happened in
your kind of process all of this so like
I said if it is you know I'm ok with it
it's just we're just weird how it ends
how it ended you know you know you have
that when you know it's the last game
you have that drive here's like well
this is the last one I didn't have that
thought that drive today you know yeah
it's just kind of like it's possible
because of everything else that's
transpired you know the NCAA but a lot
of Golden State with no families games
and all of these things so I had a
conversation with my friends about it
kind of updating them in these like as I
I'm texting this stuff I was like well
and I'm like worse the worst it's gonna
happen nuts soon and then with that you
know when you actually think about it
that way you get could be the end you
know cuz we talked about it a couple
days ago so you know you never know but
you know I'll be will I'll be around
somewhere golf course probably we just
wait for the team whatever they ya tell
us you know I'm just you know I'm not a
expert so I just follow their their
protocol and until them you know I'm
easy to find not yet you know that was
my first question don't believe it or
not when they first talk to us okay so
what's the age group 65 okay I'm good
you know but no I you know it's just
regardless I mean it's just obviously a
scary thought and you know you you feel
the word death around I think that kind
of shocked everybody just puts us in a
frenzy and and everybody on guard and
you know you can't get away from that
you know you can't read you can't never
every time you talk about this
regardless of all the precautions you
know that's what you think about and you
feel for for everyone who's you know has
a lot more to worry about then us as the
young athletes and I'm just speaking of
the athletes and you know for everybody
else so you know we just taken you know
we're just doing the right thing and
just taking the lead of our organization
and staff and who's really briefed us
and done
job of just informing us you know
because I can we don't know we just go
by what we're told and from there we
just try to hold each other accountable
being smart and washing hands and you
know making the right decisions
[Music]
I'm not one for the whole thing anyway
so you asked a lot of people around me
they'll tell you this you know I'm I'm
one morning like I'm appreciative but
you know I do my time and just walk out
the doors okay with me you know
believing that but just cool I believe
nice cool I
I just mm-hmm games been good no just my
boy who I may come back here that's it
obviously right wanting to play this
team money
with safety issues in the one again
of course I mean no that's what it's all
about is this safety and you feel for
Gobert and in being in this situation
and you know it's a lot of things at
stake when you think about this so it's
just like you know I think even worrying
about oh man I didn't get to play my
last 15 games that's selfish because I
think safety and everybody's health is
more important you know for me and
that's why I think you know yes that
question about does it feel weird yes it
feels weird but I'm ok with it because I
understand what's the bigger picture is
the safety not even for us as players
but as you move forward you know our
parents or grandparents when we get
around know that's you know where this
gets a little sketchy thing so you know
it is what it is it was meant to be this
way you know yeah it's like I was
thinking I came in on the half of season
in the lockout and I walk away from the
game kinda unfinished business which is
ok
[Music]
it's been great you know they give an
opportunity to kind of to beat me you
know all I wanted to do is just come out
and play and compete still you know be a
mentor and an outlet for these guys but
the championship is an end-all be-all
for me a champ a ring of course is what
would a goal what that goal was coming
in just like every other athlete and
sometimes you don't you don't you don't
reach it but I was one with wit with it
all and I think more so than anything I
worked so hard to be in shaping and play
this game to compete against young guys
half my age so I wanted to go out
playing the game and you know when you
say you know how was he again oh he
looks like he could still play you know
that's the feeling that's like a
championship because I think each and
every night when you're playing against
another young guy like man I don't see
how you doing it you look like you can
play a couple years that's that's like
winning a championship in my mind you
know some people probably don't see it
that way and they like how it makes you
go forward and I appreciate that but you
know I think sitting on the end of the
bench not be there cook to be a part of
this is you know that would kill me more
than anything I'd be a bitter old man
then for real so it's it's just been a
great ride